good afternoon we are joined today by
the prime minister the deputy prime
minister and ministers lametty mendicino
and blair there will be a 20-minute
opening statement followed by 20 minutes
sorry there will be an opening statement
followed by 20 minutes of questions 10
minutes in the room 10 minutes on the
phone prime minister
hello everyone
accompanied by
japanese
of dangerous and unlawful activities in
our capital city and at many border
crossings across the country
the federal government invoked the
emergencies act
it was the responsible and necessary
thing to do we did it
with three principles top of mind
first
restoring peace and order
second
doing it the right way
and third
making sure that it was time limited
the first point restoring peace and
order in our streets and restoring
confidence in our institutions
was top of mind
public safety as well as jobs and the
economy were at risk
people were being harassed small
businesses were closing factories were
shutting down and trade
was halted at our borders
here in ottawa and in other places in
the country there is evidence of
individuals wanting to undermine and
even harm
canada's democracy
their participation was believed to
increase the potential for unrest and
violence
we worked closely to support provinces
and municipalities to get the situation
under control
but as the weeks went by
it became obvious that provincial and
local authorities needed more tools in
order to enforce the law
and protect canadians
and that's exactly what the emergencies
act provided to them
learned
when we invoked the act we needed to
make sure we did it
the right way
we'll always defend the rights of
canadians to peaceful assembly and to
freedom of expression as i said before
the emergencies act was created to flow
from and uphold
the canadian charter of rights and
freedoms these measures had to be
and were
compliant with the charter
parliamentarians debated and the house
voted
we followed procedure and it is critical
that we continue to do so that's why a
joint committee of parliamentarians will
be struck to review the declaration of
emergency
within 60 days there will be an inquiry
into the circumstances that led to the
emergencies act being invoked
it will look at how we got there and why
it was required it could look at
policing the inquiry could also examine
the funding influence and disinformation
that supported the illegal blockades and
occupations both foreign and domestic
do you see
you know in 60 days
the reasons
is
we were very clear that the use of the
emergencies act would be limited
in time
when we invoked it it would be in place
for up to 30 days but we said that we
would lift it as soon as possible
we've held updates and briefs with
ministers and officials every day often
multiple times a day
and today
after careful consideration we're ready
to confirm that the situation is no
longer an emergency
therefore the federal government will be
ending the use of the emergencies act
we are confident
that existing laws and bylaws are now
sufficient to keep people safe
of course we'll continue to be there to
support provincial and local authorities
if and when needed
and i want to reassure canadians
law enforcement agencies are prepared to
deal with anyone engaging in unlawful
or dangerous activities
police officers will continue to be
there to protect our streets and
neighborhoods within their jurisdictions
support
illegal dangerous activity
it'll be important that we gain a fuller
understanding of what gave rise to this
kind of disregard for laws and threat to
our democracy
we need to make sure our institutions
are prepared and ready in the future
while the immediate emergency situation
is over
this issue
won't just go away
we need to constantly work to defend and
improve our democracy at home
and around the world
and we have a lot of challenges ahead of
us
let's remember
that we're fighting a virus
not each other
let's work together
after two difficult and painful years
we have a lot of healing to do
and now
is the time to be there for one another
mercy
okay we'll move to questions from the
room we'll start over here at this
microphone with jasmine from
is
the situation seems the same and what
has changed
in the past two days
um
tools
to deal with
and this is what we gave yeah
the various parts
with the emergencies act
uh
offensive man
monday
in
we did not want to keep this legislation
the threat the manifestation illegal
threat
protests
for blockades
existing
to prevent other occupations
glenn mcgregor ctv news uh prime
minister within an hour's drive of where
we are right now there are at least two
encampments of protesters
they are vowing to hold the line they
say they aren't going to back down and
there is a real concern of people in
this community they are going to come
back
are you willing to invoke the act again
if police can't properly respond to that
eventuality or in other places like in
winnipeg today where we see another
protest headed downtown
um
as we know
over the course of a couple of weeks the
barricades and occupations
got implanted
to a level that we felt last monday
that we needed to give
time limited proportional reasonable
charter compliant
extra tools
to our authorities to be able to remove
those barricades and those occupations
this past weekend
we saw
that happen
and as of monday
um ottawa was clear of
occupations and
border crossings across the country were
we spent the last couple of days
leaning in
with
public safety authorities with police
forces across the country
and ensuring
that
even as we recognize that the emergency
looked like it was ending
the threat remained
but that they had the tools that canada
has the tools in normal times not in
under an emergencies act
to deal with
the potential threat returning
and we got a high level of confidence
that the existing tools that
police forces have across the country
will be sufficient to deal with further
disruptions but prime minister when you
invoke the act you said it wasn't just
about ottawa you said you needed to
protect critical infrastructure border
crossings in particular airports i
believe are also listed there
those are just as exposed as they were
when you invoke the act
what's different now for them
we saw for example the blockage of the
windsor bridge
the ambassador bridge in windsor
took a number of days
and there were
some
jurisdictional questions
that prevented
the local police of jurisdiction from
being able to move in with
sufficient abilities and authorities
to be able to remove the occupation that
had ensconced itself on the approaches
to our busiest border crossing that was
part of why
very much part of why and the threats to
other border crossings and coots and
emerson and elsewhere
and the
national nature of
the threat
that led us to conclude that this was an
emergency that required the use of the
emergencies act but as i said
this was always
proportional
and time limited
and as we've gone through this past week
we have now seen and been
assured
by our police forces in jurisdictions
across the country that they now have
sufficient tools in regular times to
deal with any further challenges
and therefore
we are pleased to be able to lift
and revoke
the emergencies act
uh
foreign
[Music]
any violations of the law that happened
through those 10
days in our justice system
that will be treated as any other
offenses in our justice system
bank accounts
the process of
these accounts has already begun as the
rcmp announced
the rcmp has already asked the process
and freezing these accounts because
these
after the governor
but not because of the emergency
measures
there will be other orders
court orders and others
and because of these orders the uh
[Music]
so that all this can be validated
is
and they will proceed with this
in ottawa
[Music]
police
when the trucks arrived
[Music]
i'd
is
and uh
to use a the emergencies act as a loss
we wanted to withdraw it as soon as
possible move to the phones first
question david thornton cbc
prime minister do you still see the
protest camps outside of ottawa as a
threat
thank you david let's let's be very
clear
the threat continues uh we do see uh
whether it's social media activity or
people who continue to be
uh you know focused on
uh protesting and perhaps uh illegal
protesting that we need to be monitoring
but the acute emergency that gave rise
to the invocation of the emergencies act
10 days ago
that there were occupations
so solidly implanted that the police
didn't have the kind of resources or
tools available
to dislodge them
that
emergency
is now over we spent the last two days
hearing from law enforcement and from
public safety experts
who reassured us
that the tools available to police to
prevent
further occupations tools that were used
quite effectively by police
services in cities like toronto and
quebec city over the past weeks
would be sufficient
to prevent
even as people continue to threaten to
restore blockades or occupations
it would be sufficient
to use the tools
regularly at hand for police services to
prevent
further emergencies
so you still see these camps as a threat
but could you elaborate a bit more prime
minister do you see it as a threat to
public safety do you see it as a threat
to democracy do you see it as a threat
to canadian values just if you could
elaborate that'd be great
i think
people understand that there was
a lot of
anger and a lot of frustration directed
at
governments directed at our democracy
directed at public health measures uh
that were part of of these these
blockades and these occupations and
those haven't ended
but allow me to be very clear
people are allowed
to express their disagreements people
will always have the right to free
expression always have the right to
freedom of assembly in this country
what you don't have the right to do
is uh to blockade your fellow citizens
to cause pain
and disruption
in the daily lives of thousands upon
thousands of canadians to put jobs at
risk across southwestern ontario and
indeed the whole country
that's not a right people have and that
is something that we're going to
continue to be very strong and vigilant
against
moving on to uh emily bergeron la please
canadian
is
this information which is
confidential
we have committed
uh
taken
to ensure security and stability
in the neighborhoods of our countries
continues
until now
[Music]
and
um
yes
um prime minister you mentioned
that um
you want to be
assured that institutions are ready for
in the future if such a such an
occurrence were to happen again
um specifically what do you
think needs to change to avoid a similar
entrenchment of
some kind of protest that perhaps might
even have more sinister abilities or
motives
specifically what do you want to see
change
well i think there are there you know
many lessons we have to draw uh from uh
the past to 10 days or indeed the past
few weeks i think there are reflections
on
how
our
police of local jurisdictions are able
to
deal with uh
certain threats that were not common in
in the past years the mobilization
through social media of of
extraordinarily
motivated
crowds
is something that we need to need to
reflect on and make sure that they have
the tools to be able to manage i think
there are also reflections we have to
have on misinformation and
disinformation and
looking at how the role of foreign money
and foreign influence
in
attempts to
undermine or even destabilize our
democracy
are things that we will all
need to lean in on as a country but i
certainly hope we're able to do that in
a way that is thoughtful and inclusive
and respectful of the range of voices
and opinions
that are out there
and always
always standing up for the fundamental
rights and freedoms of canadians
as laid out in the charter and as lived
every day by canadians right across the
country
there are a lot of people who believe
that in invoking this act you've now
created a historical precedent that
really actually set quite a low bar
there were no mass occurs no
assassinations in this
street you weren't facing some kind of
militia threat so what precedent do you
feel you've set have you set such a low
bar that this will be much easier for
many governments in the future to use
i think people have seen from
both
the measured way
the
police responded the
extremely limited and proportional tools
that were put forward the full
compliance
with the charter of rights and freedoms
uh the safeguards in place and indeed
the processes for
accountability afterwards whether it's
the uh the committee of parliamentarians
or the inquiry
or
the court cases that are already
underway challenging the use of the
emergencies act i don't think anyone
feels that there was a low bar or that
this won't be fully scrutinized and
reflected on indeed
we were very conscious that
this emergencies act had never been
invoked before
and we were very aware that there would
be significant scrutiny
on our use of it and that's why we were
so focused on making sure that it was
proportional
that it was reasonable
and as we demonstrate today extremely
time limited
when the act is invoked it's in place
for 30 days
after the
the vote on monday it could have been in
place for another three weeks
but
we committed and knew
that
verifying every single day if it was
still needed
was going to be key to demonstrating the
limited and measured
use of this tool
but
we know
that there will continue to be threats
to canada to our democracy to
democracies around the world
and we cannot shy away from using tools
that are necessary to maintain the
safety and security of citizens and
that's exactly what we did in a
responsible and proportionate way
final question today is from rosemont
phileon from tevye
foreign
is
the
who were there
it
some people who became furious who
turned to unlawfulness
difficult
that is not the history of canada
[Music]
did a really good job
thank you that concludes today's press
conference thank you very much